Now that we have our project set up, it's time to start creating our neutral baseline.
Now, to cover kind of the principles of what a neutral baseline is, it's very simply put that we are trying to remove any and all artistic effects in our scene and work from a calibrated baseline.
This is very important because without a calibrated baseline, we may be chasing our tail artistically.
We're trying to over adjust or under adjust lightings. So having that calibrated baseline is very critical.
Now, some of the things that we're going to do in this scene is disable our auto exposure.
We can do that either on the project settings or in our post processing volume.
Now we'll opt to use the post processing volume as I find that that's much more flexible than setting it just project wide.
We're going to also disable all of our artistic effects, again, also through our post processing volume.
We're going to use some various calibration tools, some that ship with the engine and a few that actually come with our automotive materials pack.
And then the important things that we want to adhere to is avoid colorizing our lighting or adding any really crazy effects in our post processing.
Again, we will do this later in later stages of this class.
We'll actually go back in and add some of those artistic effects.
So this entire process is completely non destructive.
And then finally, a another important principle about having a very good neutral baseline is making sure that the materials pack is completely non destructive.
And making sure that the materials that you use to check your scene, to check your lighting are as high quality as possible.
And same thing with your models.
So to start, we're actually going to open up our zero zero start map, which is in our content classrooms and walkthrough.
Now, if you open up this file and it looks blank, don't worry.
In fact, we go up to lit, unlit mode, and you'll see that, in fact, the car is there.
So everything is fine.
Included with the project is a series of collections.
Now, collections are just a handy way of organizing content in your project.
They don't necessarily move any of your content.
They simply just help you to store these content based on various different things.
Now, if you don't see the content now, as of five dot three, I believe this is default.
It should be docked in the lower left here under collections.
And if you just expand it out, you should see the collections that we've included.
Now, with this, I'm just going to select the calibration and you can see that we have some assets in here.
Now, an important thing to distinguish here is that these assets haven't been moved to the separate folder.
In fact, some of these exist in the project.
Some of these exist in the actual engine itself.
But a collection is just a handy way of earmarking or bookmarking this content for ease of dropping it in your scene or using it.
So again, if you don't see collections, it should be rolled up in the lower left here.
Just expand it out and you see all the content that we're going to be working with.
And then finally, the other thing to keep in mind is that we're going to be using some engine content such as our skylight,
direction light and post processing volume.
And all of those can be found from the place actors panel.
So if I go back to the engine and you don't have this place actors panel, in fact, if it's closed, we're going to go up to window place actors.
And it should dock in the left.
As a point note, too, you can absolutely drag any of these windows off and dock it wherever you see fit.
So we're going to be using this along with some of our collections to pre populate or populate our scene with what we're trying to build.
So the first thing that we want to do is remove all of these artistic effects.
We also want to clamp our exposure compensation.
So to do that, we're going to do that through a post processing volume.
So I'll jump back over to the engine real fast.
And again, I'll go to unlit mode so we can see what we're working with here.
Go to your place actors.
Easiest way is just to start typing in post and we'll grab this post processing volume.
So we'll drag this into our scene.
I'm going to go down to my transformations and just click the little loop back arrow here to reset our settings.
So if I jump back, you can follow along in these slides for the different settings that we're going to use.
But essentially we are going to recreate what we see here inside of our scene.
All right.
Now, because we don't have any lights, it's going to be rather difficult to kind of see what's happening.
But essentially, our post processing is going to control a host of different artistic or visual effects into our scene.
And we will see that later exemplified when we actually have some of our lighting.
But for now, we can just follow along with this.
So the first thing that I want to do is with my post processing volume selected,
go over into my details panel.
I'm going to scroll all the way down until I see the post processing volume settings.
And the first thing that I want to do is check the infinite extent unbound.
Now, there are situations where you may want to localize or control your post processing effects within just that volume or that shape.
And that is the default nature and behavior of our post processing volumes.
However, for this, we don't want it to we don't want those effects to be contained just to the post processing volume shape.
We want them to continue to propagate no matter where the camera is positioned.
And that's what infinite extent unbound is going to do.
All right. So with that checked and we have enabled, we're going to scroll back up.
And the first thing I'm going to look for is my exposure tab.
So if I expand this out, anytime that we have a setting and we check the box,
we are now overriding whatever the default behavior or the current setting is based off a priority,
which in this case, as we only have one post processing volume, we are simply just going to change this setting.
So on our exposure compensation, I'm going to change this to negative five point five.
What does that number come from?
Simply just because of the light values that we're using, the fact that we're trying to adhere to more realistic values.
We'll find this later with our directional light.
A value of negative five point five is going to give us correct or at least visually correct exposure in our scene.
However, note that this particular parameter you can adjust up or down if your scene is too bright or too dark.
That's not the most critical component.
The next component that we actually want to change is our min and max.
In fact, this is going to be directly correlated with our exposure compensation.
So if we clamp these both at one and one or zero and zero or whatever the same value is, this essentially fix the auto exposure.
So now the engine won't try to adjust the exposure of our in-game camera or how we're viewing based off of these numbers.
So those few settings right there should be all that we need to disable our auto exposure and allow the post processing volume take effect across the whole scene.
Now, we could go in as well, as you had heard me mention, too, about adjusting some of our artistic effects.
For example, I could take chromatic aberration, check the intensity to make sure it does, in fact, overwrite at zero.
We could change our bloom intensity to zero as well.
So again, anything artistic related, disabling it.
Of course, we can always re-enable these later through a secondary post processing volume,
but simply just check the parameter itself and go ahead and set the value to zero.